[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y esto es lo
que veremos hoy en aquí américa el
espacio de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias e historias de
nuestro continente
yo vaivén quiere darle la ciudadanía a
los indocumentados los aliados
demócratas del presidente de eeuu en el
congreso presentaron su ambicioso plan
de reforma migratoria que si es aprobada
abre un camino a los migrantes para
regularizar su situación y vivir y
trabajar legalmente en el país les
explicamos en qué consiste y qué
probabilidades tiene de ser aprobada en
el congreso más de 6 mil 400 personas
fueron asesinadas por el ejército
colombiano entre 2002 y 2008 la
jurisdicción especial para la paz el
mecanismo de justicia transicional
creador y el acuerdo con la ex guerrilla
de las farc duplicó la cifra de
ejecuciones extrajudiciales estimada por
la fiscalía los conocidos como 'falsos
positivos'
y empezó el año escolar en bolivia
principalmente de manera virtual debido
a la pandemia del hobbit 19 sin embargo
miles de niños no tienen acceso a la
tecnología para estudiar les contamos
cómo van a ser desde la paz
y vamos a eeuu para nuestra historia
principal cumpliendo una promesa de
campaña de joe biden los demócratas en
el congreso presentaron el proyecto de
ley de reforma migratoria una ambiciosa
iniciativa con la que el presidente
espera abrir el camino de ocho años a la
ciudadanía para los 11 millones de
migrantes que según el migration policy
institute vivían al 2018 de manera
irregular en la unión americana
y los inmigrantes son buenos para
nuestras comunidades para nuestra
economía y para nuestro país ante todo
esta reforma migratoria proporciona a la
gente y las familias trabajadoras que
han vivido aquí por años en algunos
casos por décadas una oportunidad para
conseguir la ciudadanía por sí solos
pero nuestro sistema está roto tenemos
11 millones de personas indocumentadas
viviendo trabajando y criando a sus
familias en nuestras comunidades sin
estatus legal que son gente buena y
decente que cree firmemente en la
promesa estadounidense
veamos en qué consiste este camino de 8
años hacia la ciudadanía que se abriría
si la ley es aprobada
se crearía un nuevo estatus temporal de
5 años para los migrantes que superen
revisiones de antecedentes y que estén
al día con sus impuestos este permiso
les permitiría vivir y trabajar
legalmente en eeuu durante 5 años tras
los cuales podrán aplicar para una
residencia y permanecer legalmente en el
país tres años más mientras reciben la
ciudadanía
pero ojo solo quienes hayan ingresado a
eeuu antes de enero de 2021 podrían
optar quienes viajaron o viajen al país
después de esa fecha no califican los
dreamers o soñadores es decir los
jóvenes que entraron al país siendo
niños los beneficiarios de protección
temporal porque sus países de origen
están en guerra o porque sufrieron un
desastre natural y los trabajadores
agrícolas podrían obtener la llamada
green card de inmediato
el proyecto de ley apuesta por eliminar
los factores que incentivan a las
personas a migrar planteando una
inversión de más de 4 mil millones de
dólares en cuatro años dedicados a
mejorar las condiciones en los lugares
de origen de los migrantes especialmente
en el llamado triángulo norte guatemala
honduras y el salvador además contempla
acelerar el proceso de solicitudes de
asilo en las fronteras con el fin de
desalentar los peligrosos viajes y la
trata de personas también retira la
palabra alien del código de migración un
término que significa extranjero pero
que es considerado como denigrante por
los defensores de los derechos de los
migrantes y propone además que los
procesos migratorios de las parejas el
gmt y más sean tratados de manera
equitativa
pero la reforma no incluye un aumento en
la seguridad en la frontera una demanda
de los republicanos y de los seguidores
del expresidente de donald trump y que
podría dificultar las negociaciones en
el congreso la reforma migratoria
necesita 51 votos en el senado y 218 en
la cámara de representantes para
convertirse en ley y aunque los
demócratas tienen la mayoría en ambas
cámaras se prevé que habrá una dura
negociación
la reforma migratoria llegó al congreso
una promesa de campaña que está a un
paso más cerca de ser realidad pero que
aún tiene un largo camino por recorrer
ya en 2013 la administración obama de la
que joe biden era vicepresidente intentó
sin éxito sacar adelante un similar
paquete de medidas migratorias para que
una propuesta se convierta en ley se
necesita primero que sea aprobada en la
cámara originador a que en este caso es
el senado segundo la aprobación en la
cámara de revisión es decir la cámara de
representantes y por último la firma del
presidente que si ve que ha sufrido
muchas modificaciones podría vetarla en
la cámara de representantes los
demócratas tienen la mayoría pero no es
claro si la reforma llegaría a esa
instancia pues el senado está compuesto
por 100 sillas divididas durante esta
legislatura de manera equitativa entre
republicanos y demócratas por lo que
para cumplir con el primer paso se
necesita que al menos 10 republicanos
voten a favor con el fin de evitar que
la iniciativa en frente de un proceso de
obstrucción
una meta difícil especialmente en un
tema tan polarizante como la migración y
cuando la fidelidad del partido
republicano donald trump quedó
demostrada tras su absolución en el
juicio político por incitación a la
insurrección por el asalto al capitolio
el ex presidente es un defensor de las
fronteras cerradas
seguimos en el norte del continente un
temporal de frío que azota a texas dejó
a al menos 4 millones de ciudadanos sin
electricidad
las bajas temperaturas causaron fallas
de energía en el estado que impactaron
incluso los suministros de electricidad
en mexico ya que los envíos de gas y
petróleo fueron paralizados el operador
de suministro eléctrico del estado
erekat tuvo dificultades para restaurar
la electricidad ya que los generadores
que funcionan con gas natural y carbón
no pudieron operar porque los ductos se
congelarán en medio de la emergencia del
senador republicano por el estado de
texas ted cruz fue blanco de críticas
porque se fue de vacaciones a cancún a
veamos el informe de matías a raíz
una tormenta de críticas el senador
republicano ted cruz regreso a texas
apenas poco después de haber aterrizado
en la localidad mexicana de cancún dijo
que el viaje era para complacer a sus
hijas pequeñas
obviamente fue un error y en realidad no
debía hacerlo intentaba ser un buen
padre y todos tomamos decisiones
el momento elegido para viajar a las
cálidas playas mexicanas no pudo haber
sido peor en ojos de la opinión pública
texas el estado que cruz representa en
el senado atraviesa una profunda crisis
por el impacto de una intensa ola de
frío más de 2,7 millones de tecsa nos
estaban aún sin servicio eléctrico el
miércoles una cifra ya reducida a unos
325 mil según el gobernador greg abbott
y más de 13 millones todavía registran
interrupción en los servicios de agua
las imágenes de cruz en aeropuertos
internacionales desataron la ira de los
ciudadanos
pero que se trata desde que un hombre no
está interesado en gobernar está
interesado en destrozar el gobierno este
hombre se llevó a su familia de
vacaciones a cancún mientras la gente se
congelaba mientras se cortaba el agua la
gente
huesca el cruz uno de los más fieles
defensores de donald trump en washington
es visto como un posible aspirante a la
presidencia en 2024 el partido demócrata
del estado de texas
ha pedido su renuncia a su escaño en la
cámara alta y veamos la imagen de la
semana que llega desde martín esta es la
primera fotografía enviada por el rover
perseverance de la masa después de tocar
el suelo del planeta rojo la misión
busca recolectar evidencia de si hubo
alguna vez una forma de vida en marte y
adecuar la atmósfera para la eventual
futura visita del hombre
y en colombia la jurisdicción especial
para la paz del mecanismo creado en el
proceso con la ex guerrilla de las farc
para juzgar los crímenes cometidos
durante el conflicto armado reveló que
seis mil cuatrocientos dos personas
fueron asesinadas por el ejército y
reportadas como guerrilleros caídos en
combate entre 2002 y 2008 se trata de
los llamados 'falsos positivos' civiles
que fueron asesinados por la fuerza
pública y hechos pasar como guerrilleros
veamos más en el informe de luís muñoz
cuatro años después de la firma de los
acuerdos de paz la jurisdicción especial
para la paz se acerca a las primeras
decisiones judiciales este jueves
mediante un comunicado desempolvaron uno
de los capítulos más trágicos de la
historia colombiana elevando a casi el
triple la cifra de falsos positivos del
país civiles asesinados por la fuerza
pública y hechos pasar por guerrilleros
por lo menos seis mil cuatrocientos dos
personas fueron muertas y legítimamente
para ser presentadas como bajas en
combate en todo el territorio nacional
entre el 2002 y el 2008 la anterior
cifra de la fiscalía se situaba en dos
mil 248 y comprendía a los años 1988 y
2014 sin embargo la sep se concentró en
los seis años que hubo más falsos
positivos y que suman el 78% del total
histórico unos sucesos que ocurrieron en
los años de mandato del ex presidente
álvaro uribe vélez quien atacó al
tribunal en un comunicado
nuevo atropello de lage por 'falsos
positivos'
pero este no fue el único evento de
justicia transicional del jueves puesto
que seis miembros del antiguo
secretariado de la guerrilla de las farc
asumieron responsabilidades en
secuestros y otros crímenes de guerra
así lo expresó en twitter el partido
común es el partido político de las farc
que recientemente cambió su nombre
nuestro actual insurgente siempre estuvo
inspirado en la necesidad de transformar
la sociedad pero también reconocemos que
se presentaron hechos y conductas
sancionables a la luz del derecho
internacional humanitario' la gp es un
tribunal de justicia transicional
encargado de juzgar los crímenes más
graves cometidos en más de 50 años de
conflicto en colombia su objetivo
encontrar verdad justicia reparación y
no repetición eso pese a los múltiples
obstáculos que enfrenta hay miles de
niños que no tienen acceso a la
tecnología necesaria para estudiar pero
nuestra corresponsal en la paz mery vaca
nos cuenta como algunos de ellos
encuentran la solución
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchas gracias por esa ayuda nos paramos
chicos
hoy es un día especial para noemí
andrade y sus siete hijos su familia es
una de las primeras beneficiadas de una
campaña solidaria en la paz para
repartir equipos recuperados y
arreglados que ayudarán en las clases
virtuales de 50 familias esta primera
campaña ha resultado satisfactoria más
que todo para las personas de bajos
recursos no era el objetivo era lo que
queríamos
ayudar se ha logrado la escuela de los
hijos de noemí permanece sin actividades
desde hace más de un año fueron
perjudicados por la pandemia y luego por
la clausura del año escolar en 2020 este
año comenzaron a estudiar solo con un
celular
y la como sólo utilizamos un celular hay
que dar explorar las materias más
fuertes y además tratamos de hacerlo por
whatsapp pero aún así es complicado
aunque como son 63 de primaria y tres de
secundaria a veces no el tiempo marcan y
acá
sin embargo hoy están contentos con dos
equipos más van a ser muy útiles yo creo
que como estamos en clases virtuales
ligón ojo necesitamos siempre un más de
un celular porque como somos muchos
hermanitos nos va a ser muy útiles
rodríguez aparatos
los hijos de 9 y tienen los equipos pero
eso no es suficiente ya que la conexión
a internet y el sistema educativo en
bolivia están entre los últimos de la
región una realidad que ha empeorado por
la pandemia
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí a américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho y sigan viendo france24
[Música]